kind of regular chess from for a little  while  so yeah also it's just we've got a  praise Duda it's not just Magnus playing  badly it's due to playing really really  well yeah yeah I also want to stress  that it is also Duda but I maybe you  think that it might be to do with the  fact that he's already the Melt water  Champion's chest tour winner and uh you  know he would have been riding high  after that because this is what he has  been playing for all year yeah and he  won it yesterday so it kind of feels a  little bit flat now and we often see  this actually in a lot of situations  where someone achieves their goal and  then the very next day  they lose so I mean we saw it with  napoleoni when he won the candidate you  know he won it with a round to spare and  then the final game he lost and he's uh  over Magnus Carlsen is knocked out of  aim chess rapid by John Christoph Duda  what a match by the young polish player  he is ready for the final winning two  games